there have been a lot of celebrity
endorsed products over the years some
have been ridiculous
some of them cringy hey guys i'm hulk
hogan
but very few of them have actually been
good and among this pile of
failing a-lister american celebs one man
stands above
in canada aviation american gin if
you're drinking anything else
you're drinking [ __ ] welcome to a
daily youtuber's channel guys as we know
purequality here
today's the first installment of
marketing mondays where we demystified
the success
the disasters of the marketing world
we're gonna be answering the age-old
question today in episode one how do you
make people
watch an ad traditionally the answer's
been force
force down their throats with a
commercial brother but
it's 20 21 guys that feels a little
aggressive in a time where kids know
consent is cool so the real question is
how do you make people
want to watch an ad to consent to it the
answer
normally has been to use celebrities but
the problem is it doesn't normally work
out as planned
put popular people in sterilized
scripted environments something still
feels off even in multi-million dollar
photo shoots
with the best copy editors in the world
you know that chris rock really doesn't
care about the 5g network of verizon
wireless this
is a game changer 5g 5g 5g
5g not only that you could replace chris
rock with literally any celebrity and
the result would be the exact
same not exactly inspiring so you tune
out the ad
but you know whose youtube channel
hasn't been tuned out ryan freaking
reynolds this man has accumulated almost
half a billion views
just organic traffic no ppc required and
the content
all ads for like random stuff you
wouldn't think or viral successes
gin okay maybe objectively the worst
alcoholic beverage
sorry guys you've got budget mobile
wireless and you've got dating websites
okay not exactly a recipe a trifecta for
virality but if you're like me and you
thought that you're an idiot
because millions of people tune into
this kind of content with the most
popular comment being that this is the
most popular type of ad that people
would
willingly watch and to the marketing
skeptics like me
who know that views don't equal
purchases you should know that these ad
campaigns have been enormously
successful for the companies that he's
partnered with
mint mobile had a huge surge in
popularity and aviation gin just sold
for 600 million
dollars that's right million now of
course success is never just one thing
but viral marketing always helps so what
is he doing right
it's three things it's funny it's
self-aware and the brand
always looks good now most celebrity
endorsements i've realized after
watching a bunch of them way too many
nail number three the brand looks good
look look at that chris rock commercial
right
the iphone looks beautiful the whole ad
actually is just this beautiful thing
but it's not funny it's not self-aware
and in fact it's just
all staged and boring now a rare
exception to this is the celebrity
endorsement that hit one and two it's
funny it's self-aware
but these often come at the expense of
the brand take for example
bill burr he's a hilarious example of
this he always insults his sponsors as
he reads them
right out of the bat this sounds creepy
to me
video doorbell uh
will insert dinging sound what does that
mean i was supposed to
insert ding dongs all right let's do
that again our built-in rechargeable
battery
put your mind at ease and protect your
home and your parakeet
[Music]
with the video doorbell time magazine
named one of the top 10 gadgets
of 2014. sure it'll kill more porpoises
because eventually you have to throw out
the wires
and they will end up in the ocean but
right now my listeners get
the ring video doorbell for only 174
that's 25 off the normal price
still kind of expensive though you know
the door
house comes with a doorbell already
attached he's still making payments
anyways okay you're coming out of that
it's funny it's self-aware but you're
not gonna buy a ring doorbell if
anything you're not gonna buy it anymore
but sitting somewhere right in the sweet
spot is an ad that manages to be funny
self-aware
and makes the brand look good all at
once take for instance this ad within an
ad
within an ad where ryan reynolds buys
mid-roll ad placement for his gin
company
my new movie six underground is so huge
you're gonna want to watch it on a
bigger
better samsung qled tv oh
aviation gin how'd that get there now
that's good
advertising and if you're thinking that
the only reason this ad works is because
gin is fun
let's talk about 5g with the mobile
carrier network okay
it's about as exciting as dental work
but watch this
it's hard to believe that 5g is as
amazing as everyone is saying so
we've brought in mint mobile head of
technology rizwan kasim to explain it to
us riz
well 5g is substantially more spectrally
efficient with lower latency so it's an
order of magnitude's improvement over 4g
[Music]
it seems we may never know what 5g is so
we're just going to give it away for
free
with every plan until we can figure that
out you just gotta bow to the master
well played ryan reynolds you managed to
make three million people voluntarily
sit through an ad
well played indeed all right that's
basically it i hope you enjoyed this
episode of marketing mondays
if you did leave a comment below letting
me know who you'd like to see
next featured next on marketing mondays
it can be great advertising it can be
terrible advertising but i thought we
take a little
diversion from the usual scams that we
talk about and talk about
real advertising that either succeeds
works really well crushes it
or completely bombs and we'll analyze it
on this channel
let me know if you enjoy it see you in
the next one